this is a presentation that i'm doing in
part because i've been teaching bentham
for a long time
in intro classes and ethics classes in
modern philosophy classes
and he's an important figure
particularly in moral theory
and over and over and over again we
teach him as just a consequence um
if we actually start looking at his text
you see there's a lot more to his his
ideas
and
i'm going to lead you through some of
those today
this mainly has to do with with what we
call philosophy of action um since a lot
of you are
in andrei bucharam's class a lot of you
know this term philosophy of action
because that's one of his his
specialties it's also something that i'm
interested in from a somewhat different
more historical perspective so
when we think about bentham if you if
you haven't encountered them yet
these are the sort of things you're
going to typically run into these are
the the
general understanding the sort of you
know footnotes or cliff notes version
he's the father of a
movement philosophy called
utilitarianism
that ends up orienting itself around
what's called the greatest happiness
principle so if there's only one thing
you remember from your ethics class
about bentham hopefully that will
that will be it
um it's a quad it's a consequentialist
moral theory meaning that it pays
particular attention to
what happens when we do actions and it
evaluates whether actions are good or
bad based on whether they have good or
bad effects good or bad consequence it's
going to better outcomes
um there's a few other things that are
kind of quirky about bentham that i
wanted to get out of the way right away
if you don't know about these some of
the some of them may be a little bit
shocking to you
um
there's what's called the auto icon and
there's a whole story behind that you
can tell later on and then he's also the
theorist of of an important
idea in
criminology called the panopticon so
this is the automatic
jeremy bentham's reserved corpse
at university college london
preserved according to his will well the
only part that's not actually preserved
of it is his head that's a wax hat
um so if you're going to talk about
bentham inevitably this comes up i
wanted to sort of get it out of the way
right at the beginning so you know we
can we can talk about that later if you
want but
you know
i wanted to to sort of clear the area
that the other idea is the panopticon
and this is an interesting idea in
phenology or you know the theory of
prisons
and the idea was you wanted to create a
new kind of prison where people would be
under surveillance all the time or at
least think that they're under
surveillance all the time you may hear
sometimes references to the panopticon
society
in places where they have a lot of
cameras and you never know which camera
is running or who's watching it so
bentham is the originator of that but
those aren't the things that i'm going
to talk about tonight
those are interesting little little
features
he's the father of utilitarian
philosophy so what do we typically mean
by this um
when we're
looking at that well like i said it's a
consequentialist theory
it's hedonistic meaning that it focuses
on pains and pleasures it reduces all
moral values ultimately to pains and
pleasures
the greatest happiness principle is at
the center of bentham's moral theory and
if you want to boil it down it says a
moral evaluation should judge in terms
of everybody's pleasures and pain so you
want to look at what is going to
maximize human happiness
minimize human misery and you can
understand these in terms of pain and
pleasure
he provides something that he called the
hedonic or prolific calculus
a means by which to calculate this sort
of thing those of you who are going to
be business majors or you know do a few
other types of things along those lines
may run into this in terms of cost
benefit analyses
it's very similar to what bentham is
doing
um now is this is this enough
this is enough for like you know
teaching him in ethics
or perhaps even in in some other classes
as well
none of it's wrong
but that's not all there is to to bent
them
this is kind of a caricature like i put
here it's
what is a caricature it has the broad
outlines of something but it's a little
bit distorted it doesn't give you the
full picture
so how can we discover a fuller
understanding of bentham and i i think
there's three
main
ways or main approaches that we can take
one is by doing good textual work
i'm a historian of philosophy so what
that means is
i read texts if i want to know what
descartes thinks i got to read what
descartes actually said there's no way
around that i want to read everything
that the guy wrote if possible so that i
can get the whole picture you know if
you wrote a letter to somebody
about some issue that you know comes up
in another text i probably want to read
that letter because there might be
something there a lot of what you're
doing in that case is actually reading
stuff that later on you're not going to
use because it turns out you don't
actually need it
but good research
done in that way good textual work means
you actually have to take a look at the
the text and what are they saying
good historical work you also want to
look at historical figures
in terms of how they fit into the
history of ideas not just the history of
philosophy but the history of culture
and civilization in general bentham is
an important figure in that and then
good comparative work how does bethlehem
address the sort of issues or problems
or controversies that other similar
philosophers are are doing are looking
at you know does he
skip over things
that that we might want him to take away
so i put a diagram here
i think that these all reinforce each
other and this is what it is
or this is an understanding of what it
is to do good history of philosophy
in this case to understand bentham
so i'm going to skim over some of this
fairly quickly because we're not
actually going to do
much with the history of ideas we're
doing more textually oriented work
looking at what is he actually saying
but i do want to sort of fill in the
gaps for you give you a kind of
guidepost to where this guy
sits
there are some some traditions that
utilitarianism is kind of bringing
together and you may have encountered
some of these
figures in in other classes maybe not
necessarily philosophy it could be a
history class where they're mentioned or
a political science class thomas hobbs
for example
how many of you heard of thomas hawkes
there's quite a few
john locke
about the same amount david hume
less oh that's surprising how about adam
smith
that's surprising because usually we
hear about smith in terms of economics
and the invisible hand and capitalism
all of them are actually doing something
that will feed in to utilitarianism
bentham actually references
all of these people except for hobbs who
it was a little bit dangerous at the
time to you know identify with
then there's some other figures that are
not quite so well known i'm actually
going to skim over that because you guys
are isn't it
we're going to make this sort of an
introductory level thing since that's
where most of the students are
there are some other european
enlightenment thinkers that are any of
you planning on being a criminal justice
majors
in here we've got a few so you may
actually encounter
beccaria who is an important theorist in
the
understanding of punishment
bentham is actually reacting to him and
drawing on him this other guy helvetius
then bentham gives rise to a whole
movement he coins his term
utilitarianism he was in some ways the
right guy at the right time to bring
together a lot of threads of thought in
a very systematic way
and he give gives rise to an entire
movement that is still going on today
somebody like peter singer would be
an example of a contemporary utilitarian
another important part of the history of
ideas
utilitarianism is like one of the great
you know boogie men for all sorts of
other
theorists who move for right or for
wrong sometimes they're they're on
target with their complaints sometimes
they're off target poets in particular
love to attack utilitarians because they
are reducing everything to utility
sometimes they're on track sometimes
they're not
bentham was also a contributor to
legal reforms one of the one of the main
motivating
drives for his work was changing the
british legal system which at the time
that he was engaging it
um
it was you know
fairly irrational and corrupt he
actually spent a lot of his his inc
writing about that
now
usually if we're going to teach bentham
we teach the introduction to the
principles of morals and legislation
and we usually only teach
several chapters from it
but it's actually a much larger work and
he did intend it to be an introduction
to principles that's you know
the general ideas behind morals what's
morals ethics
he understands that you know more or
less
synonymously and legislation so there's
also political philosophy and philosophy
of punishment
he also wrote another book much later on
that doesn't get read very often but is
important to look at if you actually
wanted to work on them called deontology
it's a little bit misleading to call it
that because
normally we think of deontology we think
of kant or or other moral theorists who
are focusing primarily on duties and are
not you know utilitarians
but um
he actually used the word for for this
uh
text that he wrote um it was published
posthumously he's got a table of the
spring of actions you might say well why
are we looking at a table well you'll
you'll see the table in a moment you'll
see how detailed it is and it's worth
actually looking at especially with its
explanations
he wrote a piece about the promulgation
of laws that had some interesting things
to say
he had another work called the
instruments of invention and discovery
and then bentham was big at making up
words so he's got nomography
which is basically about laws as well
almost as law graphic is writing
and
all of these are important to look at if
we want to understand his philosophy of
action
this you can't see very well you can get
some sense of just how detailed this is
this is bentham's table of the springs
of action
bentham was nothing if not systematic
this is a guy who when you read him he's
going to be really boring to read
admittedly rewarding if you put in the
time but very boring because bentham
loves to make all sorts of enumerations
you guys have all encountered that you
know and uh you have to kind of force
yourself to read it but when you do it
actually is kind of you know it pays off
and being interesting
these are all the different kinds of
pleasures and pains that cause our
actions
to be the way that they are to get us to
do the things that we do bentham tried
to come up with an exhaustive
enumeration of them
so now we get to bentham
and the philosophy of action we talked
about very briefly the history of ideas
we've talked about which text we're
going to look at
i showed you one of you know the text
we want to talk about philosophy of
action now so
when we're talking about bentham's
velocity of action we can't actually
separate it completely from his moral
philosophy what we call philosophical
anthropology or theory of human nature
and his his political philosophy
and what i'm asking here is if we
combine these perspectives
what sort of interests and issues are we
bringing to our study of bentham's texts
and
oftentimes these are the things that we
come to the table with if we're going to
re-bent them
we're interested in moral evaluation of
actions consequences
whatever else that that would be in an
ethics class typically right
um or maybe we're interested in critique
of current institutions society you know
that sort of thing maybe we're in a
political philosophy class in that case
or maybe we're doing ethics and we have
a more socially oriented
way of doing it
another possible response maybe we're
looking at what motivates human beings
um
in order to change society along
utilitarian lines the people who are
actually part of the utilitarian
movement today
you know that's that's that's their uh
their project
what else do we want to understand
if we're talking about philosophy of
action and i'm glad that we we have so
many students that are getting some
introduction of the philosophy of action
uh you know in these intro classes
these are the sorts of topics that we're
really interested in you know first of
all whether human action is free or
determined
that's a big question
when you make a choice
are you actually choosing freely or is
it something causely somewhere in the
background
make you make that choice that's a
that's a big question or could it be
both there's there's a position that we
call compatibilism which is probably the
more interesting one you know because if
you if you say it's both you've got a
lot of explaining to do don't you
um what are the most fundamental
motivations for human actions this is
you know one of those questions that's
never going to go away we're always
going to be asking about that
what makes people do what they do
what are the distinct human motivations
or desires
what's the full range of these are some
of them normal and some of them abnormal
you know do we all have the same
basic desires or do they vary
we want to know what the roles of the
human will and the intellect are in
producing action or guiding action
we want to know how people actually
reason things out if they do maybe maybe
they don't actually reason things out
there they just want to do things
or maybe it's you know a sort of
less conscious process of reasoning
which we could reconstruct you know we
want to know that sort of thing
what role does what we call affectivity
and affectivity includes all those
things that you you feel you desire
your urges
your your moods all those sorts of
things are affectivity
we want to know whether habitual
dispositions actually exist or not and
what role they play do they do they get
us to do things do they not how do you
produce them how do you get rid of them
and then you know um one of the the
things that i'm particularly interested
in is what we call a crossy or weakness
of will when you
you know you know what the right thing
to do is
and you find yourself nevertheless doing
something else
and while you're doing it you're like
boy i shouldn't be doing this
that's what we call lacrossia
you know some something went wrong
somewhere and we want to be able to
figure out you know whether that
actually
is a good description of what's going on
and
what causes it
now bentham's own work you know if you
want to know something about the person
that you're
reading if they've actually said
something about their own work that's
the best place to go
presumably they know their own writing
better than anybody else right
bentham gave an evaluation of his own
work in the forward to the introduction
so the major work
and he's talking about um
what's good about his his work and
what's what's bad about it and he was
you know fairly
self-critical guy
he said that he thought that the
chapters that deal with actions
intentionality consciousness motivations
dispositions and consequences
were among the best chapters that he
wrote in that work
some of those are our chapters that
actually get paid attention to
some of them are
less
often frequented by people reading
bentham's text so if you really want to
see what bentlem is up to
you probably want to look at those
so you know what was he interested in
one of the things that keeps coming up
over and over again
bentham was not just interested in
putting forth the moral theory or
changing the legal system
he wanted to develop what he called the
logic of the will so he wanted to find
out
you know not just what makes us do the
things that we do but how do you
actually systematically
put these things together
how do you structure this sort of thing
he says there is or rather there ought
to be a logic of the will as well as of
the understanding
the operations of the former faculty are
neither less susceptible nor less worthy
than those of the latter of being
delineated by rules the typical
them there
i'm going to skip over the numberography
one he talks about the promulgation of
laws he says if the laws were actually
founded on reason
they would infuse themselves so to speak
into the minds of the people they would
form part of the and again it uses this
term logic of the people
they would extend their influence over
their moral nature so he's interested in
how do we understand the will
systematically
now there's some problems
bentham likes to use the word will
and never defines it
never actually analyzes it
so you know if we're going to approach
this and this is
particularly important for students who
are approaching it for the first time
what philosophers typically mean when
they talk about the will
these are some of the the main things
you know a faculty of choice able to
choose between alternatives to decide
between goods
something different from just mere
affectivity something that can actually
like you know say i've got desires for
this but i'm going to hold off from it
i can interface and listen to reason a
reflexive faculty you know very often
when you have a theory of the will the
will can not only determine say whether
my hands are going to do this or whether
i'm going to walk over here or walk over
here the will can actually determine
itself
and so it's reflexive
and we also look at it as often being
the locus of
moral character or moral education or
the moral dispositions depending on how
complex of the notion of the will you
have
what does bentham say about the will
he likes to use the word
he doesn't like the words voluntary and
involuntary he thinks they're too
ambiguous so he sort of strikes them
from his uh
his character
and he also says some things that are a
little puzzling
in the observations on the table he says
employ the term free will to the
exclusion of the term free will employ
the term necessity
the language so employed will not be
found to be expressive of any real
difference
so what does that tell us
that tells us you know over here we've
got what we call libertarianism there
actually is a free will you make free
decisions
at least some of the time over here
we've got you know
the hardest of hard determinism
everything is totally determined
causally
you know determined ahead of time by
things that you can't possibly
uh change but you could predict
um somewhere in the middle is
compatibilism bentham must be some sort
of compatibilist because he's saying
this and this they're basically the same
thing it's one of the strangest passages
in in bentham's
works he also says an act of the mind so
everything that you're doing when you're
thinking is either an act of the
intellectual faculty or the will
acts of the intellectual faculty will
sometimes rest in the understanding
merely without exerting any influence in
the production of any acts of the will
there are some things that you think and
then there's things that you decide to
do that motivates you and he's
interested particularly in those
he uses the term in multiple sentences
sometimes he means intention
because he actually identifies he says
will or intention and he's using them
synonymously
at other times he seems to talk about
the will as this general faculty that
produces human action
the will is the locus where these
different forces are competing against
each other and eventually something
comes out of it
the will is also determined through
whatever information and inferences that
the intellect is able to supply to it
so we want to ask how does the will
actually work for bentham how is it
determined
he tells us the will necessarily yields
to the solicitation of the greatest good
so this sounds fairly familiar and you
know the sort of history of ideas the
will
um
yields to the the solicitation of the
the greatest apparent good whatever it
is that we you know if we have
good over here and good over here if
this seems to be a better good my will
turns that way
how should we understand this
one way we could understand this is a
very intellectualist view
where practical reason
working with the information it
possesses tells the will hey go after
that good because that's the better good
maybe it could be wrong you know maybe
maybe reason
didn't get all the information and it
thinks that this good over here is
better than it is but the basic working
would be you know reason figures out
which of these goods is the best one
tells the will go after it the will says
all right i'll do that and then the will
gets things going
what gets everything moving
well
what gets everything moving the first
place though is desire or affectivity
so how do we understand this bentham has
a very clear answer to this
pleasure and pain this is one of the
things that's that's particularly
attractive about bentham's theory and i
actually when i say attractive i don't
mean attractive to me i'm not a
utilitarian i'm just somebody who likes
reading bentham and
talking about him
i actually think he's wrong in a lot of
points
but i like the the the fact that his
theory is very clear
very coherent
um that you can tell where he's going
with things
he tells us this at the very beginning
of the text that you are probably going
to read if you read and event them
nature has placed mankind under the
governance of two sovereign masters pain
and pleasure
it is for them alone to point out what
we ought to do as well as determine what
we shall do so there's two points being
made there on the one hand the standard
of right and wrong so moral philosophy
on the other hand the chain of causes
and effects human motivation
are fastened to their throat that's his
his stunning piece of rhetoric that he
begins the uh
the
introduction
he goes on to say they govern us they
govern us in all that we do and all we
say all we think every effort we can
make to throw off their subjunction
subjection
will
serve but to demonstrate and confirm it
speaking in terms that again if we want
to bring in a little his uh history of
ideas this almost sounds like the way
that people back in the middle ages used
to talk about divine providence
it's almost exactly the same kind of
language
now how does this work
when we start getting down on the nuts
and bolts it's all very fine to say yeah
pain and pleasure make us do everything
pains and pleasures in certain ways so
bentham the first thing that he really
starts talking about are sanctions
and when you hear that term sanction you
probably think about getting in trouble
right and he does have something like
that in mind although it could be it
could be punishment or it could be
reward
and
he talks about four sanctions in the
introduction again the work you're most
likely to encounter later on he refines
his theory so it includes five
and
the sanctions that he talks about are
ways pains and pleasure
as final causes as things drawing us
become what he calls efficient causes
the things that make us do what we do
and these sanctions he comes up with
with four or with four of them
originally five later on there's the
physical
physical sanctions are
you know if you um
here's an example this is not super hot
coffee
but imagine it was right if i drink it
what happens
do i feel pleasure
what do i feel
pain and what can like burning sensation
right so i learned pretty quickly hey
don't drink super hot coffee
that's gonna that's gonna hurt next time
and the next time around maybe i blew on
my coffee right it modifies my behavior
um you give me coffee and i take a sip
you know i haven't had say let's say
it's some kind that i haven't had before
and you say
dr sadler try this out i said well okay
that's good
i think i'll drink some more of this
again modified my behavior right these
are what we call the physical sanctions
they're they cover a lot of things and
he has to do with you know
learning from pleasures and pains that
have nothing to do with anybody else's
wills
now you can say well but i got you that
coffee
yeah okay but once i've actually got the
coffee in my hand it's just me and the
coffee right
or if i decide to jump down the stairs
rather than walk down the stairs and i
trip and you know
get smashed up
i've learned a valuable lesson right
don't jump down the stairs
now if you push me down the stairs
that's a whole different matter that
wouldn't be the physical sanction that
might be something else
he then talks about the moral sanction
the moral sanction is what we call
public opinion
and ethics falls into this rebecca
um
what about you know what people are
going to think of us if we do certain
things how do people react to us
you know does their their exhibitions of
pain and pleasure modify our pains and
pleasure i mean think about how you
learn not to be a jerk
right every one of us has done some
things that were kind of jerky at one
time or another and
somebody else came along and said knock
it off don't do that i don't like you
when you do that and then we learn okay
quit being a jerk right it's very
straightforward very simple stuff we
also learned hey if i act this way i'll
get i'll get rewards that i like
then there's the political sanction this
means you know the laws
the the actual political structure
and some people you can't reach with the
moral sanctions so you've got to
sanction them by say
punishing them
um you know various things bentham was
big on talking about you know
imprisonment and
we have other ways of doing that
there's the religious sanction which he
thinks is particularly inefficacious
the religious sanction means appeal to
what god is going to do to you you know
either god's going to like you or god's
not going to like you and bentham kind
of pushes that aside because in part you
know for one thing bentham doesn't
actually believe in any of that stuff
but he had to sort of you know give lip
service to it but also in part because
he thinks that you know those pleasures
and pains are so far off that we don't
really worry too much about them and
then he's got this thing that later on
he introduces called the social or
sympathetic sanction and this means the
people that are closest to you your
family and your friends you care more
about what they think don't you
than about what other people think
things work a little bit differently
with them you've chosen to at least you
know friends family even when you get
you know older you've chosen to be with
them and to care about what what it is
that they think
so you can see how these all fit in
together i created a kind of diagram
here that gives you some idea
about it
how do these actually work
he says
they're at their efficient causes
they determine the ways in which
pleasures and pains are produced they
help to determine your will what he
calls prospectively so they make you
think about what consequences are going
to follow from your actions and that may
you know keep you from doing certain
actions or or incline you to doing
certain actions they also like he says
determine a person's will
retrospectively you screw something up
you suffer and then you say wow that was
a bad idea for me to do that
not only do you feel you know sort of i
better not do that next time you look
back on you say that was a bad action
for me to do
ideally he says these sanctions should
promote what he calls the principle of
utility
now is this all there is to bentham's
views this is already quite a bit isn't
it
there's a lot to take in
you know if you're
starting to get a headache or something
like that i can be kind of sympathetic
with that because that is a lot
there's yet more
um
does this actually accord with with
bentham's text
if it did his texts ought to be a lot
shorter than they are
we know they're not he goes into these
lengthy analyses of all sorts of things
like
motive disposition passion virtue and
vice
so maybe one possible answer to this is
to say all these moral concepts are just
ways of thinking about pleasure and pain
that's one way to to approach that and
there is some truth to that um
and we'll see why
he says that that really you should
evaluate things on the basis of
consequences
ultimately
but is is that all that's going on
what does he actually say this is why
it's important to go to the text he says
the effects of an intention to do such
and such an act or the same objects
which you've been speaking of under the
appellation of its consequences so
there's that
and the causes of intention are called
motives so motives have a
role there says a man's intention on any
occasion may be styled good or bad
either to the to the consequences of the
act or with reference to his motives so
again motives assume some sort of
uh moral role
if it be deemed good or bad in any sense
it must be either because it is deemed
to be productive of good or bad
consequences or because it's deemed to
originate from a good or bad
motive so really we have two different
ways of evaluating
intentions and as we'll see other things
as well
what are the consequences do they have
good or bad outcomes
and what is motivating the person what's
getting the person to do what they're
doing
now
ultimately consequences are still the
most important
but what i wanted to to do this this
presentation for
was to call attention to the fact that
that's not all there is motives still
play some sort of role
true a role that feeds back into
consequences but it's a role that gets
us to do the sort of things that we do
and bentham is very interested in this
um
i'm going to skip through that so if we
look at bentham's key ideas right we
have consequences those result from
actions what gets us to do our actions
we have intentions and the intention can
be either just to do the action
sometimes and we don't actually think
about what we're doing and sometimes it
turns out good sometimes bad
or sometimes we do the action just
because we want the consequence you know
show up to class at eight o'clock in the
morning are you showing up to class at
eight o'clock in the morning because you
really love getting out of bed and going
to class at eight in the morning
i don't think so
you're you know
you want to be
present for the class because it fits
into some sort of structure of
motivation that you have you know and
you want certain consequences namely
getting a good grade right
intentions and and dispositions and
motives um they're arranged in a kind of
set of uh
connections with each other um
intentions are caused or determined by
motive so motives are more fundamental
um intentions and dispositions
dispositions he says are the sum of a
person's intentions so really
dispositions are kind of a reflection of
that and what about dispositions or
motives a disposition is evaluated uh
based on the nature of the motives that
a person is have to be influenced by so
again
motives are much more important
um if we look at these key concepts
again now it's starting to look a little
bit more like your life
right you not only have intentions
actions and consequences
you have dispositions
somebody can ask what is this guy likely
to do what is you know what is this
woman uh inclined to do in these sorts
of situations those are dispositions
and how can you tell what somebody uh is
like well you're gonna watch them for a
while right and you don't just pay
attention to the actions if you can
figure out what their intention is
sum those up and now you know they're
dispositioned about them let's say
but
what drives all of this
is motives
and motives are like he says a general
kind of desire
for for something so he tells us
on every occasion conduct is at the
absolute command of
and is the never failing result of the
motives
that means they're pretty important
by a motive he says is to be understood
anything whatsoever which influencing
the will of a sensitive being is
supposed to serve as a means of
determining him to act or voluntarily to
forbear to act so it's anything that can
get us to go in a certain direction and
we'll see you know what he means by that
in a moment
i want to skip over the other quote
when we're evaluating motives he wants
to evaluate them in terms of pleasure
and pain he's a critic of our current
use of language so we might say that
somebody is motivated for example by
lust right that's a motive that somebody
has to do something
but what is lost lust is sexual desire
right
is sexual desire in and of itself a bad
thing a good thing
maybe something neutral
depends on the consequences for
men what kind of activity what kinds of
of
action is it going to ultimately produce
so he is going to categorize
nine basic kinds of motives and this is
the list
benevolence that's the best motive for
him that means to to do good to other
people to to want to do good to other
people it's when you
are happy that somebody else is happy
then you're benevolent you obtain
pleasure by giving somebody else
pleasure
desire for reputation all of you
understand that people like you you feel
good
people don't like you you feel bad that
can get you to do things
desire for amity
very similar
reputation has to do with a sort of
public uh persona amity has to do with
when people actually do really like you
or at least you feel like they really
like you um
we all have a natural tendency bentham
thinks to to want people to to like us
and that can get us to do a lot of uh
things good or bad physical desire what
does this mean
everything from you know
wanting to have a sip of coffee because
i i don't actually need to you know wet
my throat i'm not thirsty but
it tastes pretty good
and i like things that taste pretty good
so i want to have it all the way to
wanting to lay in the sun or wanting to
get out of the sun when you're starting
to burn sexual desire all these things
are comprised in physical desire
self-preservation that's a motive you
need to have
otherwise you're going to have a lot of
trouble right
desire for power
desire for wealth
those are motives
malevolence what is malevolence it's the
opposite of benevolence it's when you
want to when you're going to take
pleasure
in somebody else's being harmed or hurt
and think about anger for example
bentham really doesn't like anger
in the deontology his classification of
the passions pays almost exclusive
attention anger he says never good
why because when you're angry what do
you want to do to the other person
make them feel good
what do you want to do
come on all of you get angry right
some of you probably get angry today
what do you want to do to another person
what do you want them to feel
when you're angry
what's going to make you feel better
when they feel
pain right and malevolence
anger is just one form of malevolence
malevolence is taking pleasure in
somebody else's pain or also feeling
pained by somebody else's pleasure
finally there's motives of religion
bentham says these are all over the map
i'm not even going to speculate about
them so he doesn't really
worry about it
instead of using terms like good or bad
right off the bat he thinks we need to
think about these differently now
remember bentham is a utilitarian so
that means that he thinks everybody's
pleasures and pains are important we
want to take everybody into
consideration
there are what he calls social motives
these are the things that tend to get us
to behave in
good ways in society ways that tend to
promote other people's happiness
benevolence is all about other people's
happiness right so that's going to do
that
more or less guaranteed he he worries a
little bit about what he calls
restricted benevolence where you're only
interested in your your class
your group your you know restricted
um
society and not about people in general
but in general benevolence is the best
desire for reputation desire for amity
provided your society isn't totally
screwed up desire for reputation is
probably going to be leading you to good
ends desire for amity
you know you're probably going to behave
in fairly decent ways if you want people
to like you again unless you surround
yourself with people who are totally
screwed up
um dis social motives
well malevolence right
if you want to hurt people if that's
what gets if that's your main desire
you're probably not going to be very
good company
are you
and then there's what he calls
self-regarding motives and you know you
got to watch these a bit
um because you know they can they can
lead us to to favor our own pleasures
and to avoiding our own pains at the
exclusion of other people but he
understands that these are
legitimate
dispositions and motives this is the
last thing we want to get to talk about
how do we fit dispositions of this so a
disposition he says is a kind of a
fictitious entity he doesn't think that
dispositions really exist they're a kind
of
being of reason as they would call it
back in the the scholastic days uh an
entity that we we create so we can give
a name to something
they express what they're supposed to be
permanent in a man's frame of mind
where they've been influenced by such
and such a motive
later on he just uses the word habit as
well as virtue advice instead of
disposition
now what makes a disposition good or bad
it's the motives
he says
so he talks about
hey again he uses this very fancy
language tutelary or seducing motives
right
tutelary or preserving motives these
prompt a person to engage in in action
that's generally good so you know for
example um you know benevolence
benevolence is a tutelary
it to you know it teaches you right
teaches you to do the right thing it
preserves
the good good disposition seducing or
corrupting motives they prompt a person
to engage in an action that's generally
bad
think about self-preservation
if you add one other thing to the mix
like say you're a paranoid
right
what does it mean to be
paranoid
offhand with anybody
easy definition of it
what's what's wrong with the paranoids
perception of the world
everything looks too nice to them
how what's wrong with them yeah
it's dangerous yeah they perceive
everything as being threatening as
hostile
and so if you have a natural instinct
for self-preservation which by itself is
not bad
but you add to the mix that you're a
paranoid
uh now you're going to think everybody's
out to get you and that you better get
them before they get you
and then suddenly in that those sort of
circumstances self-preservation can
become a corrupting motive
now like it says a good disposition is
going to depend on susceptibility to
tutelary moments it doesn't mean that
you're motivated by all by them all the
time it just means that you tend to be
more influenced by them than bad motives
think about when you get angry for
example you get angry do you nurse your
anger and say i'm gonna get that person
i'm gonna make them suffer
you know sometimes people say not only
you know i'm going to teach them never
to cross me so you know somebody did
something minor to them and now you're
going to do something really major to
them so that you can make a spectacle of
them and nobody will ever mess with you
again
that's going to be a pretty you know
seducing motive right there right um now
we may feel temptations about that sort
of thing but do we do we give in to them
or do other motives influence us instead
do we have a you know the good angel on
one shoulder the bad angel on the other
shoulder the good angel actually saying
no no benevolence
or even self-preservation don't go and
attack that guy
you don't know what he's carrying
um
that might actually be a preserving
motive in this case so dispositions are
how we're affected by this
virtue invites bentham does not use
these terms very much in his early works
in part because at first he thinks that
they're
misleading
later on he actually tries to redefine
virtue advice
he he says ah not going to be able to
get rid of this language i better take
it out
and he says that only in so far as it
produces happier misery can an act
properly be called virtuous or vicious
virtue and vice are but useless
qualities unless estimated by their
influences on the creation of pleasure
and pain
the ghania calls them fictitious
entities as any disposition would be
spoken of as real for the purposes of
discourse and without fictions of this
character on subjects such as these
discussions could hardly be carried out
he thinks that
without these we can't actually
make sense of things and he tries to
reduce the virtues down to two virtues
which is kind of an interesting move
it says what are the really valuable
virtues
the all the other ones come out of that
so he says prudence
you know
which is looking out for yourself
taking care of yourself
it's self-oriented
and then beneficence beneficence goes
beyond benevolence benevolence is just
wanting to do good for other people
wanting other people to be happy
beneficence is actually doing it
actually
engaging in behavior that's going to
make other people happy he says beyond
these there's no intrinsically valuable
virtue every other virtue traces back to
one of these
so we've covered a lot of stuff
hopefully you've seen that motives play
an important role in bentham's moral
theory and his theory of action
they're not just something to sort of
skim over if we can help it
you can see i hope how some of the other
parts fit in with each other and now we
get to the
q and a
part of it
and again remember i'm not i'm not a
utilitarian myself i just sort of play
one at the podium
i know you've got a question because i
saw you shaking your head earlier
i think it'd be good to hear what a
philosopher of action makes of is
that the mess you know
what
uh
yeah i mean you know do you find this
plausible or
well i think that his views are
being quite similar to those appealing
yeah
yeah
so it seems like i mean i wouldn't take
issue with anything
i'm see i'm i'm sort of unconvinced by
bentham's
stuff i find it really interesting
any other questions comments
things that it provoked
it must be perfectly clear then